Invincible honest trailer let's do
this I feel like the streaming trailer
thing isn't oh God I walked I talked
over my name relationship focused and
Hyper violent comes a reinvention of the
superhero genre listen I I love the fact
that I got a name check in this uh it
was a real big ego boost uh I live in a
house where my wife and kids are in no
way impressed with what I do uh and so
that was a that was a pretty cool moment
but uh uh using it to point out my
crutch dirty pool dirty pool uh am I the
violence guy sadly yes but uh let's try
not to draw too much attention to it I
uh there's some originality to my work
right maybe no all right makes it more
grounded relationship focused and Hyper
violent Look Out movie musicals you're
about to get
Kirkman I I don't like the cats
reference I mean think uh I think I
think it's dated I think it's really you
know that we're doing this a little a
little bit after uh this honest trailer
came out uh because uh there was a
massive gap between Invincible one and
two let's just go ahead and address that
I think that the Honest Trailer you guys
at fandom uh you're better than that
you're better than that we're now we're
looking at a cat's joke like two years
too late cor comes another Grim story
about how superheroes would behave if
they were we'll just move on over the
Lex Luthor Jeff Bezos uh uh comparison
because I don't agree with that I think
he's a great man
meet Mark Grayson an ordinary teen who
discovers he secretly part alien and
possibly part Canadian sorry I'm so the
Canada shirt a lot of people ask about
the Canada shirt I don't think I've ever
talked about it publicly we went to
Toronto on a vacation and uh my son who
was younger at the time I'm going to say
13 I don't remember and uh uh he went to
a gift shop and they had a that red
shirt that just said Canada across acoss
the front of it and he thought it was
hilarious that there was a shirt that
just said Canada and uh had nothing else
on it so for a good two and a half year
period my son wore nothing but Canada
shirts and so Cory Walker who's you know
Uncle Corey to my kids uh dear family
friend co-creator of invincible uh when
he designed young Mark he put my son's
Canada shirt on Mark so that is the
reason for the candidate shirt so that's
a that's a fun Easter egg that only my
family likes the entire Canadian
animation team on season 1 thinks that
it is a reference to them it is not
sorry about this I've been an and I'm
sorry I didn't realize that sooner sorry
sorry sorry hi sorry sorry sorry I'm
sorry I'm sorry I'm sorry I'm so sorry I
am so sorry I know I'm sorry
I suck he's an every man sopa uh who's
the the co- show runner on Invincible we
we working on season one and he is
Canadian and so I give him crap every
time he throws out a Suri instead of
sari uh and so he actually uh uh now
uses the English pronunciation of sorry
because uh he's sick of me giving him
crap about it and I'm very proud of that
go USA for the Zoomer generation which
means he's extremely depressed horny and
resents having to actually do anything
with his abilities I can't believe I
still have to exercise but he'll have to
harness all of his strength to battle
exotic villains protect his friends and
gain one single clue across an entire
season of Television hey I didn't invent
the rules what rules it's kind of like
peeing your pants on purpose what what's
going on what oh okay I love that Mark
is a terrible superhero in season one of
that was by Design um the idea is that
Invincible is going to go for I'm going
to say a 100 seasons and the you know
ideas that we're going to get to see him
grow and evolve and change over time and
actually become a competent uh
impressive superhero who actually is
capable of doing things with his
abilities but we started him at a very
different place in season 1 and he is
terrible and he does lose almost every
fight and uh I love that the audience
has embraced that and uh seeing it key
in here in this honest trailer was
pretty neat there's so much you don't
know Mark what okay your Superman and
your dad is Thanos Mark you are a comic
book nerd you should get this
immediately get to know wild characters
like omn man a guy with the most
intimidating superpower of all dad
strength he's Mark's father and a clever
subversion of every so omn man has a
mustache because my father had a
mustache uh growing up and uh Corey
Walker dad had a mustache growing up and
so we just associate mustaches with dads
uh and so we were like we'll give him a
mustache so he looks like a dad and then
Invincible is a very very serious drama
uh that is a serious character study
with serious Stakes but we thought it
would be hilarious if there was an alien
race that just had mustaches for no
reason whatsoever and so that's why the
mustache then became a Vite thing and I
love as the show
progresses we will get to see a wide
variety of different mustaches on our
vilter Mite characters as we introduce
more and more of them and uh does it
detract from the seriousness that we're
trying to achieve with the show yes is
it possibly a
mistake probably but uh do we enjoy it
would we change course now at this point
no not at all so uh it's a it's we have
our fun every boy fantasy that their dad
could beat up your
dad like this there's also Amber Mark's
girlfriend who totally cracked his
secret identity totally you know I'm not
an idiot I figured it out weeks
ago who was that the police are on their
way where the hell did you go maybe she
was playing uh uh you know cool there I
don't know or maybe that was a mistake
who knows the Guardians of the globe the
Washington generals of superhero teens
they're here to do two important things
kill time until Invincible or omn Man
shows up and I think this is borderline
to critical but I'll be okay with it you
know it's it's funny it's one of those
things where I I enjoy Honest Trailers
myself and I watch them all the time and
then to see that thing you enjoy turned
on you is uh is pretty heartbreaking and
I don't enjoy it but I'll allow it
because it's fun when I'm seeing you
guys do it to somebody else so it's fine
but I mean I think that they are very
capable superheroes who do cool things
but uh you know maybe their scenes are
killing time I can't really say 24 years
old I'm a 30-year-old genius in a
teenage boy's body I never expanded
myself to that extent that was
intense explore a vast and entire so
look is almost everything happening in
the show involving monster girl and
robot and their children bodies uh super
weird and uncomfortable and easily
something that you can make fun of yeah
absolutely and the whole point of that
entire weird thing is to draw attention
to the fact that Superhero universes are
absolutely bizarre and we're trying to
embrace that in Invincible uh these are
two characters that are uh adults that
are trapped in child bodies but it's
something that you don't really discuss
in an uncomfortable way uh but we do
acknowledge it and uh you know follow
those stories to where they're going to
go um and I think that having that
weirdness there where the audience is
watching it going I don't know what to
think of this this is this is very
bizarre uh is kind of like paying
tribute to the fact that like Bruce
Wayne and Dick Grayson like live
together and then they would hang out at
night and go crimes grab it with your
teeth and Dick Grayson wasn't Bruce
Wayne's son and people make endless
jokes about it but in the purity of
comic form it was something that was
just fine for many many decades and
there are many examples of weird things
like that existing in comics that are
just kind of like understood and glossed
over and so we're trying to like pay
tribute to that but we get it it's weird
a vast and entirely original comic book
Universe when it was first published
back in 2003 that took care to update
some of the old tropes but still has a
ton of jokes she'll be hearing the
second time around like clones who can't
decide which one is the original I'm the
original he told me you're the Clone
what do you think he told me you're the
Clone fashion designers who secretly
specialize in hero costumes I'll strive
for iconic Nets a friendly alien voiced
by Seth Rogan are you using your time
out it's probing time and robote headed
bosses I've got money it gives me no joy
to do this because clams will be doing
it jeez there are multiple animated
comedies featuring wacky robot
Godfathers maybe we should try a new
genre once in a while hey anyone up for
bringing back the horny ski comedy I
think we're going to get started on that
horny ski comedy superhero show uh I
love the acknowledgement that uh I think
aside from VI Futurama all of those
things did happen in Invincible first it
just took us an embarrassingly long long
time to actually get around to adapting
that comic uh we're celebrating our 20th
anniversary this year and I feel very
old but uh thankfully we're now doing it
and uh uh hopefully we'll eventually get
to later issues where other people
didn't do things that we had done in the
comic already so it seems uh like we're
uh second to the
party so Marvel let a show so dense with
aess celebrities it's super clear that
Amazon can afford to give its drivers
bathroom breaks or at least improve the
animation when it's not part of the
fight scene I'm just going to laugh
quietly at this of a '90s cartoon with
tons of fun twists recurring jokes
and hey wait I wasn't done okay why
would you drop the credits like that the
episode clearly isn't over there's like
two more minutes left see starring so uh
I love that the after credits thing is
becoming a gag it was something that
really started with the Iron Man movie
and then has gone to some pretty like
like interesting and ridiculous places
in a lot of different movies over this
now like almost two decades of time uh
since like after credits thing be after
credits became a regular thing and it's
something that we love playing with on
Invincible uh we do it every single
episode sometimes they're Monumental
scenes sometimes they're like some kind
of cool addendum to something that
happened in the episode but what's
really neat is with season 2 we are
doing some super off-the-wall bizarre
things with the after credit sequences
that I'm really excited for people to
get to see so uh uh it's it's really a
lot of
fun Justice me pict these are always
great wa I'll do it how I pet your
mother wish a little mean girl nickm the
Pink Ranger no come on Jason manukas
robot's not D Jason manukas is a great
actor explod something maybe your nuts
and Subway he does do a lot of uh he
does do a lot of AD living I will say
sometimes too much Jason we write these
scripts for a reason don't go too
far sometimes it hurts my feelings but
no Jason is uh uh he's a real character
and and uh a lot of the best lines that
Rex blod says are just things that he
would throw out in a recording booth
that uh we ended up keeping in because
we thought they were funny do you guys
notice the Invincible shirt that I put
in that other movie where I voed an
alien you see you plant the seed and
then you the
plant don't give Seth broken credit for
that that shirt is there because of me I
actually got contacted by a guy named
Clinton trucks who was helping uh uh
Simon and Nick because they were they
wrote that movie uh put together their
ComiCon scene there's a there were big
Comic-Con scenes shot for Paul and uh at
the last minute Marvel n DC didn't allow
them to use anything and so he called me
and I rounded up a bunch of people from
Image Comics and we gave them the rights
and but yeah we gave them all kinds of
stuff and then they ended up uh having
this invincible shirt in the movie but
in one of the cutcenes because they
established that Simon's character was
an invincible fan uh Kristen wig who's
in the movie actually wears Adam Eve's
costume and they filmed scenes at for
the end of the movie that they didn't
use where they're at another ComicCon
and she's with them in Cosplay and uh
Cory Walker was on set I was on set Ryan
otley was on set and we got pictures
with Kristen wig in anatomy of costume
she even had like a a red wig and uh it
it was pretty cool but uh it didn't end
up getting used in the in the movie I
don't know if you've seen the the Aaron
sorin videos where they'll take like
like full lines of dialogue or full
phrases that he puts in every single
project and it'll just be like eight
straight minutes of people saying the
same thing over and over again in like
12 shows and 13 movies and I live in
fear of someone doing that with my work